well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the new
statesman's rachel cunliffe and the
deputy political editor of the daily
mail john stevens with us from now until
just before midnight welcome to both of
you as ever though time to look at the
front pages starting with the telegraph
which reports that boris johnson is
losing support from within his own party
as the shadow of the alleged downing
street parties haunts number 10. the eye
says the pm's future is in jeopardy as
conservatives hit out at the government
johnson faces potentially terminal
showdown over danny street parties is on
the front of the financial times
the guardian says mps are urging the
prime minister to come clean over
whether or not he attended the party
the metro suggests the prime minister
has contempt for the victims
the mirror declares
the party's over boris the male goes
with the same pun saying no cabinet
member will defend the pm is the party
over for the prime minister
a softer tone from the express don't
blow it now they say
and the star invokes the sitcom yes
prime minister in their criticism of
boris johnson
well just quickly you can check out the
front pages yourself of tomorrow's
papers by scanning the qr code that you
can see on your screen right now
it will come i'm told uh right now not
quite uh but we're joined now by rachel
cunningham and john stevens as you can
see um well john let's start with you uh
your paper and the telegraph which we
kick off with um both uh tory supporting
newspapers um raising real questions it
has to be said
yeah well this party rally we know has
been bubbling on since uh the end of
last year but it's been a really grim
day
for the government i think there were
two really striking things today in
parliament one was the picture of the
tory back benches when there was that
urgent question about this issue and
there were hardly any tory mps there mps
just don't want to be anywhere
associated with this total mess the
government's got itself in and the other
striking thing was the absence of any
cabinet ministers out on the airwaves
today with a junior health minister out
on sky and other breakfast programs this
morning but the rest of the day we
haven't heard any things in the cabinet
they've been totally silent on this i
think that is gonna be really concerning
for them in number 10 tonight that
they're worrying about is the support
within the toy party now starting to ebb
away from the prime minister
well he can't duck it forever he's got
pmqs
noon wednesday rachel what might he say
and will that be the subject of
a long hard thing amongst his advisers
tonight
i wouldn't want to be one of his
advisers
that's one thing that i'll say i think
that the the challenge is that if he
comes out and denies being at the party
uh and then it turns out that he he was
there well that just adds to the the the
list of offenses against him um and i
think it's it's not just about will the
conservatives turn against him although
that is obviously a key issue and the
lack of ministerial and backbench
support really striking it's also about
the public it's worth noting that
there's a new opinion poll which says
that two-thirds of the british public
think that he should resign if it turns
out that he he did break the rules and
that is up 12 points from the numbers
that thought that when it was the
previous party revelations which were
obviously the ones over christmas um
which was a
again showing that this has really got
cut through and i think the reason it's
got cut through is because everyone
remembers where they were that that week
in may 2020. everyone remembers the
sacrifices that they made the the people
they didn't see the loved ones they
didn't say goodbye to the funerals they
didn't go to the education that their
kids didn't get and indeed the people
that they lost due to covert so it's not
something the government can just say
oh we're doing a report on this we're
doing an investigation and we'll get
back to you later the anger is is
stronger than that yeah and we saw your
paper briefly there john britain is
fizzing with anger boris must apologize
and show humility only then can he
survive that question though is the
party over for the pm do you think it is
well boy johnson has always defied the
odds when a lot of people have written
me off many times in the past he's
managed to bounce back somehow so i
don't think that we can say with
absolute certainty this is the end of
boris johnson's leadership but he does
have a tough task on his hands i'm not
quite sure how he manages to get himself
out of this one when we've had the other
party allegations he's been able to say
either that i wasn't there and i didn't
know what was going on or he suggested
it wasn't really a party what was going
on was a business meeting but in this
case we've all seen the email invitation
that was sent out talking up bring your
own booze talk about enjoy the sunshine
he's not able to say this time that it
was a business meeting it quite clearly
was a party and we know that boris
johnson was there in the mix of it
although today he's refused to say
either way whether he was there or not
but i think
downing street's refusal to slap that
one down suggests that he definitely was
there and so if he was there and if it
was a party i'm just not quite sure what
defense boris johnson can have apart
from putting his hands up and saying
sorry and we know how difficult it's
been for boris johnson to say story
about things so i think one of the
things that will be
wearing them in number 10 is what more
is to come out on this we know we've had
loads and loads of revelations i think
one of the things that they are
particularly worried about is the
possibility that someone may have taken
a picture of this party in the garden in
number 10 and we know what the reaction
was before when we had that picture of
them in the garden of number 10. i think
that's also something that's worrying
tory but benches they think that every
time dump number 10 seems to be able to
tidy this up starts to get back on the
front foot and move things on this party
gate story comes back to haunt them i
think they're just a starting to be a
feeling on the tory back benches that is
this a real problem for boris johnson
that he doesn't seem to find any way to
be able to move on from this row and
that's got them starting to think about
maybe it would be better if we had
someone else in number 10
yes and anger in some quarters has
turned to genuine puzzlement that any of
these events would have been been even
remotely thought uh suitable to carry
out um dame angela eagle uh in the last
few minutes saying that he misled
parliament in december uh will the
misleading of parliament be the
the crime of this in the end rachel
i think you've got to look at the
mechanisms for removing
a prime minister if you want to think
about which way this is going to go
because you could say oh the public
pressure will get so so extreme that he
will resign because it will be untenable
for him to continue that isn't really
the way that boris johnson has operated
in the past so we're not due an election
for at least another couple of years so
it's going to have to be the
conservative policy that gets rid of him
now they are traditionally very very
ruthless and aren't going to do that
unless there is a clear successor and
one of the challenges at the moment is
that a lot of the cabinet are themselves
implicated in in some way or at least
even if they're not at the moment there
are concerns that they might be because
as john said we don't know what is still
to come so until there's a clear game
plan for what to do when you get rid of
him uh i i don't think they're going to
be that likely to move on it um we've
actually got some analysis from the new
statesman today are asking exactly that
saying it's not enough just to say how
can he continue you have to ask how
could he be forced to not continue and
that's a more complicated question
it does seem though like more is to come
because it seems that every time the
government seems to have moved on from
from one of these party scandals seems
to have emerged pretty much in tax bam
there's another one and i think uh
blaming dowling street staff for the
christmas party for the allegra stratton
video which was the prime minister
tactic there where he said i'm terribly
terribly terribly sorry that all of my
staff broke the rules and i'm as upset
as you are you know that was his defense
that it wasn't him or his government it
was junior downing street style well
there are quite a lot of downing street
staff who maybe have a less charitable
view of their employer or former
employer now and so if there are videos
or pictures of any of these events now
you've got a lot of quite upset people
who might have an incentive to share
them yes and the metro in fact uh john
has the picture that you were talking
about that's the 15th of may uh the uh
pm picture there with uh carrie uh their
new baby dominic cummings and martin
reynolds who is the subject obviously of
of this
investigation i guess with the uh the
email uh sent from his account um will
he survive it does he need to survive it
some suggestion uh last night that he
was going to be the four guy in all of
this uh come the inquiry revelations
what's your thought
i think it is quite tricky particularly
for him you know we've all seen that
email where he sets out what was going
on you think for a senior official in
downing street to think that that was an
appropriate thing to do i think it is
probably quite likely he will go now
also there's new revelations in the
telegraph tonight about how he
potentially took part in another party
last christmas and so there seems to be
particularly a lot of steam building up
behind him and suggesting that he will
have to go however i just don't think
it's gonna be possible now for boris
johnson to say here's my sacrificial
lamb here's the guys who's going and we
can all move on i think this now is a
lot more at boston's own door and i
think mps wants to hear from him how on
earth is he going to get out of this
mess
the scottish conservative leader
obviously douglas ross saying that if mr
johnson had
broken the rules or misled parliament he
should resign um
will it be any defense the defense we
heard from from to be fair very few tory
mps today uh michael fabricant was one
who said it um this rabbit warren of
rooms our offices and the garden's an
extension of the office and so on does
that simply not wash when it's a byo
party
i think you've got to make a distinction
between the law and the guidance and i
realize that's confusing a lot of police
officers found it very confusing during
the lockdowns uh but there were there
was that the law which was
when you were allowed to be outside and
then there was a lot of guidance about
how to interpret that law um so it's
quite possible for people to argue look
darling street is a complex warren of
rooms and buildings and people came
there to work because sometimes they
worked outside and maybe they had a beer
outside maybe they didn't you know that
was still working but the government had
published guidance that specifically
said if you were an employer and your
staff weren't working from home if they
were working there in person you had a
responsibility to maintain distancing
wherever you could and to discourage
social mixing and an email saying come
on guys bring your own boobs let's let's
enjoy ourselves does the complete
opposite of that is that a criminal
offense i think a defense lawyer would
be able to argue that it might not have
been breaking the law it was certainly
breaking the guidance and unfortunately
it was the guidance that the vast
majority of the country
was adhering to at that time and it was
about the guidance that a lot of police
forces were enforcing sometimes in a
very heavy-handed way and i think there
are lots of people who have been
fined uh or harassed in some other way
by police forces for supposed breaches
of lockdown rules that were far far
less clear-cuts than this downing street
garden party so there's a double
standard
there too in that
the government downing street isn't a
little its own sort of self-contained
bubble where the law doesn't apply uh
people working there should be treated
the same way as anyone else well i think
everyone including mark harper who's
quoted in the guardian chair of the uh
covert recovery group who said these are
serious allegations the prime minister
will be in the house of commons on
wednesday and i await his explanation
with interest i think the nation
probably says the same does it not but
uh let's go to the daily telegraph shall
we smart motorways what's the latest
so smart motorways is this incredibly
genius idea that if you want to increase
capacity on motorways you don't have to
build more motorways or expand them you
can just use the hard shoulder which is
this lovely empty lane on the side of
motorways i mean anyone who's ever been
stuck on the on the m25 will know the
urge to drive in the hard shoulder um
but the idea is that you don't need the
hard shell that what you need are lots
of cameras monitoring the motorway so
you can drive in all of the lanes and
then if there's an accident or if
somebody sort of pulls over the cameras
will flag it immediately and they will
somehow with some wizzy technological
solution that i don't understand
make it safe so the drivers don't go
into the back of that car anyway lots of
great idea wonderful lots of evidence
that's come out over the past couple of
years that shows that it doesn't really
work or even if it could work in in
theory in practice the cameras are all
broken people aren't monitoring them and
there have been deaths related to people
getting stranded in those live lanes so
we're not going to do it anymore until
we have more evidence which you'd have
thought they'd have tried before
starting it but i don't know i don't i
don't work in traffic management what do
i know uh let's move to the ft uh john
for our final story um this warning from
the uh world health organization uh that
half the european population could be
infected with omicron within the next
two months in fact within six to eight
weeks which in itself is astonishing
isn't it
yeah and that's the thing that seems to
be with omicron that it seems to have
spread so widely i don't know about you
but so many of my friends and family
have got the virus over the last couple
of months compared to previously when it
seemed like hardly anyone i knew had got
the virus and obviously one of the big
problems with this one of the rows that
going on here at the moment is if you
get so many people getting the virus at
the same time and have them all
isolating then you start to get problems
with public services you start to have
so many doctors and nurses off that you
aren't able to run hospitals properly
your problem with schools you have
problems with transport you have
problems with getting goods to people
and so it just seems a real problem if
you have loads of people getting the
virus all at the same time
well john stevens rachel cunliffe thank
you very much indeed for now both of you
good to see you